you guys ever think about dying
we finally get to witness a Barbie girl
in a Barbie world I mean what a time to
be alive or a doll Barbie the movie is
about to be unboxed in theaters and
while this isn't the first film based on
a popular toy line from our childhoods
this may very well be the most
intriguing highly anticipated and pink
film ever here is everything you need to
know before you go see Barbie
[Applause]
I'm coming with you okay Come on Barbie
let's go party sorry I could not help
myself the Barbie Corvette Wheels were
finally put into Motion in 2019 when
Greta Gerwig was attached to write the
film alongside her partner both
professionally and personally Noah bound
back Greta of course was later added as
director of the movie because well duh
I've got the World on a String Gerwig is
probably best known for her
oscar-nominated films ladybird and
Little Women in fact she was actually
the fifth woman to be nominated for best
director at the Oscars and her partner
Noah's biggest hits include the squid
and the whale and the oscar-nominated
marriage story it's almost like Greta
Noah or like real life Barbie and Ken
anyways while their impressive resumes
don't necessarily scream Barbie movie
that's actually what makes this even
more enticing did you bring your
rollerblades
I literally go nowhere without them now
as far as who's bringing this Toy Story
to life it's a whole bunch of actors
that we really love first and foremost
is the main Barbie character played by
two-time Oscar nominee Margot Robbie who
also served as a producer through her
company Lucky chap entertainment and I
just gotta say it's kind of really hard
to picture anyone but Margot playing the
iconic doll but maybe that's just me I'm
in the movie and because Barbie needs a
Ken sometimes anyway Ryan Gosling is
donning the platinum blonde as the main
Ken and I gotta say there's really no
disputing here that Goss has always been
our Ken IRL so cool now the reason I say
that Margo and Ryan are playing the main
Barbie and Ken is because there are
actually other versions of the
characters as well much like the toy
line itself why they chose to name
almost every single doll Barbie and Ken
is beyond me and thanks to the film
trailer and those epic cast posters that
were released we know that other
variations of Barbie include Issa Ray as
president Barbie Alexander ship as
writer Barbie Dua Lipa as mermaid Barbie
Hari Neff as Dr Barbie and Kate McKinnon
as weird Barbie you have to want to know
okay do it again I actually asked the
cast what's the weirdest thing they ever
did with their Barbies and Issa Ray's
answer will literally have you cackling
we beat that Barbie I don't know what it
is now on the Ken side we know that
Shang Chi star simulu and the next
person to play Doctor Who shooty gotwa
will both be playing Ken along with
Scott Evans brother of Chris Evans and
John Cena who is playing merman Ken I
mean I need that doll stat there's also
the classic doll Allen and for all of
you scratching your head saying who is
Alan Alan Alan is Ken's friend and
played by Michael Sarah as well as
Barbie's friend Midge who's played by
Emerald fennel interesting backstory
here Midge was actually a pregnant
Barbie that Mattel ended up
discontinuing that had a romantic
connection to Alan in Barbie lore but
TBD if they'll be linked in the film the
movie also includes non-toy characters
AKA humans that will include America
Ferreira and Will Ferrell who both
happen to play Mattel employees and of
course the narrator of Barbie is Helen
Mirren can we just take a second and
talk about Helen's range from playing a
therapist in Kendrick Lamar's video to
being the narrator of Barbie she really
is a Dame
okay so now that we know who's writing
directing and starring and Barbie what
is it actually about well there are sure
to be plenty of interesting twists and
surprises still to come but we did
finally get a little run down of the
premise in the main trailer for the film
so in it we see that Margo's Barbie is
having a bit of an existential crisis
when her feet turn flat and ends up
leaving her near perfect existence in a
place called Barbie land
[Applause]
along with Ryan Gosling's Ken who never
goes anywhere without his rollerblades
as they head into the real world to try
and figure some things out I gotta just
stop and say that the arch foot scene is
literally my favorite in the trailer and
I asked Margo if those were her actual
feet in the movie and here's what she
had to say they on my feet I woke up we
had little sticky bits on the floor for
the like double-sided tape for the shoes
so they wouldn't
come off so that I could get my feet out
of them and I was holding on to like a
bar but that's it I wasn't like a
harness or anything like that so back to
the plot when Mattel figures out that
Barbie and Ken are out of the box and in
their world the CEO played by Will is
determined to send them back to where
they came from and along with all those
happenings we're definitely going to see
plenty of classic toy references and
callbacks to please even the most
die-hard Barbie lovers out there oh I'll
see you tonight in my dreams no now
let's talk about the long and storied
history of America's favorite doll and
my personal best friend because I had no
friends when I was five no one's asking
you to be perfect and how we got to the
first ever live action movie about her
because this isn't about me keep in mind
there are over 40 animated Barbie movies
dating back to 2001 covering a vast
array of original storylines along with
reimaginings of classic fairy tales now
when it comes to live action though the
first real Rumblings began back in 2009
with Universal Pictures and then again
in 2014 with Sony Pictures before
emerging again in 2016 with Amy Schumer
briefly attached at one point although
creative differences made that a
short-lived possibility oh my God you
have no idea what a huge relief that is
fast forward to 2019 when things finally
got moving with the addition of Margot
Robbie and later Greta Gerwig and boom
here we are
[Applause]
and looking even further ahead because I
have trouble staying in the present
Greta actually told vulture in 2021 that
the idea of this becoming a full on live
action movie franchise quote would
certainly be exciting now something
tells me the box office numbers May
determine how that future shapes out but
I mean I am already down for a solo Ken
movie Margot Robbie said this is the
greatest version of Ryan Gosling will
ever see on screen and I don't think
she's wrong but I'm a man but not a
doctor can I talk to a doctor you are
talking to a doctor I need a clicky pen
No a sharp thing no of course we can't
talk about the history of Barbie and I
would be a horrible 90s baby without
mentioning the 1997 hit song Barbie Girl
from Aqua now the song was not actually
affiliated with Barbie in fact the
powers that be actually try to separate
themselves from the song for years
before finally embracing it so I'm sad
to report that the song will not be used
in the movie as we know it but happily a
new track called Barbie world by rappers
I spice and Nicki Minaj will be featured
with a sample from aqua's original and I
gotta tell you it
all right dolls that's everything you
need to know before you go see Barbie in
theaters July 21st thanks for watching
and be sure to rate and review this film
at rottentomatoes.com my name is Naz
Perez and I can confirm life in plastic
is fantastic
[Music]
foreign